in this video I'm going to talk about
g-protein coupled receptor or GPCRs so
here you can see on the surface of the
cell membrane you can see a seven
transmembrane domain receptor
transmembrane is a portion which is
incorporated inside the cell membrane so
it has seven transmembrane domain each
transmembrane domain containing alpha
helices and this receptor is also known
as serpentine receptor and this receptor
is associated with a trimeric g protein
and this trimeric g-protein has three
subunits alpha beta and gamma this alpha
subunit usually binds to gtp when it is
in a inactive State and now what happens
a poly ligand binding to the g-protein
coupled receptor these trimeric g
protein undergoes a conformational
change and this trimeric g-protein now
exchange is its GTB with GTP this
trimeric g-proteins alpha subunit
exchange GDP with GTP once bound with
GTP this alpha subunit is activated now
this alpha subunit as you can see is
dissociated from this beta gamma partner
and this alpha subunit can go and
activate adenylate cyclase so here you
can see the adenylate cyclase enzyme and
this adenylate cyclase enzyme it can
perform the conversion of ATP to cyclic
a MP now cyclic a MP is a very important
second messenger note that ATP cannot be
a second messenger because there are
plenty of ATP in the cell so cell need a
distinct type of structural molecule to
be a second messenger and let his voice
and chooses cyclic MP instead of ATP or
only MP however cyclic a MP represented
as this dotted structure will go and
bind to protein kinase a or also termed
as PKA
for cyclic EMP molecules bind to this
regulatory domain of protein kinase a as
you can see protein kinase a has two
basic type of domains and it has four
moments two regulatory domain two
catalytic domain cyclic EMP binds the
regulatory domain and releases the
catalytic domain the catalytic domain
migrates to the nucleus here you can see
the catalytic domain migrates to the
nucleus and it's phosphorylate the crimp
protein the creep protein is cyclic AMP
response element binding protein so the
scrape ones get phosphorylated it will
bind to the cyclic EMP response element
it will help to transcribe many
important genes so one good example of
this g-protein coupled receptor mediated
signal transduction we can find it in a
chemical signaling all the chemical
receptors are actually g-protein coupled
receptors however if we want to see The
Cribs structure in the cyclic AMP
response element binding protein
structure we will see that it has a DNA
binding domain as it will bind to the
DNA so it must have a DNA binding domain
it has a C terminal DNA binding domain
it also has a site where this
phosphorylation occur now another type
of signaling downstream signal can be
carried out by this same receptor and
ligand interaction and that is via
phospholipase c gamma beta and that is
where phospholipase c beta this upon a
different ligand binding this trimeric
g-protein will be activated and this
alpha subunit with associate alpha
subunit will go to phospholipase c beta
and activate it and phospholipase c beta
it will clip pip to phosphatidyl
inositol
bisphosphate and it will cleave pip 2
into ip3 and
so ip3 is no satori triphosphate it's
another important second messenger and
be a G which is diacyl glycerol so it's
along the second messenger it is also
important for activation of protein
kinase C and in protein kinase C
function so as you can see if we
highlight this bipto molecule it will
look like something this it has a
inositol group here it has a phosphate
phosphodiester type of linkage now it
has a chain where two fatty acid is
linked so plc gamma or plc btec any
phospholipase c will cleave in this area
so phospholipase beta or phospholipase C
gamma anything will cleave in this pond
however when ip3 is generated it's a
second messenger so it will carry a
signal and it will go to the ER the
endoplasmic reticulum on the endoplasmic
reticulum it will bind to specific
channels and it will open the calcium
ion channels so the stored calcium ion
in the ER will get out into the cytosol
here you can see stored calcium ion will
get out in the site or cytosol and this
calcium ion can also activate protein
kinase C or this calcium ion can bind to
cam kinase and it can impart its
function
so this g-protein coupled receptor
signaling is essential for chemokines
function and if we think about the
clinical point of view it's very
important because cholera toxin ATP to
ADP ribose islets the g protein actually
cholera toxin put a a DP ribose i'll
group into the jeep in the G protein so
it will modify this G protein by putting
our ADP ribose oil group once it put the
ADP ribose L group here it actually
activates the gtp
the alpha subunit by Unbound with GTP
and upon activation it will be activated
forever I mean it would be activated
constitutively so once it is
constitutively active all the downstream
signaling pathway will be there so what
happens in the coal era the cyclic EMP
level goes up and the protein kinase
activity is also increased so what
happens this protein kinase a as it is a
kind is it phosphorylate the exchanger
of sodium and hydrogen in the intestinal
epithelium and it also phosphorylate
CFTR so however the ultimate result is
the flux of sodium chlorine ion and also
the water into the gut and that results
in severe diarrhea so this is how the in
cholera g-protein comes into play and
this is how g protein is important okay
thank you like subscribe and please
comment